exercises for Sawadee what getting up
okay this is an exercise that's often
overlooked but as a really nice one to
go through very slowly a lot of control
miss as a position in this I do it in a
few different counts first thing I do
they come up on the balls of my feet so
here my knees are down but I'm not most
of all my feet from this position as
smoothly as I can bring my knees up here
in balance so this is a hard position to
balance from especially when you're
doing it my premium can use very very
slow in control then from this position
and a race to standing in a controlled
way again I'm going to lower myself and
I bring my hands down I bring my knees
down you don't want to pound it into the
mat I want to get used to slow using the
strength of my hips to lower them down
with a nice smooth transition down and
then again I'm going smoothly flat
myself out so the steps in this is to
come to the toes rest off needs bout
hogs up down controlled knees down
control and flat this exercise will
increase the strength in your core and
your legs and help you a lot in your
size of practice getting up from cezzah